we're going to begin with politics
specifically the political fight over
the supreme court vacancy have you heard
and new claims from senate republicans
at least one key senator says
they already have enough votes to
confirm justice ruth bader ginsburg's
replacement
before the election even without knowing
who president trump will nominate
ginsburg will be honored on friday as
the first woman
ever to lie in state at the u.s capitol
the president who campaigned in ohio
last night says he'll reveal his choice
either the same day that happens or the
day after
ben tracy is at the white house ben what
do we know about the president's
decision
well good morning the president says
that he's considering five different
women but that
two are top contenders in cbs news has
learned that he's already met with one
of them
in person the president is now using
this court fight to shift the focus of
the campaign from coronavirus
to this issue that fires up his base and
that he feels helped
get him elected back in 2016.
a lot of presidents get done we've had
three it's blowing their minds
at yet another packed campaign rally in
ohio monday night
president trump teased his supreme court
pick
probably saturday we will announce the
nominee
and it's somebody that you're going to
have great respect for great respect
thank you
thank you big stuff that's a big thing
you know they set the course of our
country for many years to come
the president is pushing to get his
nominee on the court in the quickest
confirmation since sandra day o'connor
was appointed
in 1981. i'd rather see it all take
place
before the election so before november
3rd are you concerned if you lost the
election it would be harder to get the
person
no i don't think so no i think we're
going to win cbs news has learned that
48-year-old amy coney barrett
a federal appeals court judge and a
favorite of religious conservatives
met with president trump at the white
house monday
vice president mike pence told cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell
that the goal is to install
anti-abortion rights judges
at all levels are you convinced that
judge barrett
would overturn roe versus wade what i'm
convinced of is that judge barrett
and the other finalists on the list will
interpret the constitution in a way
that's consistent with the great
tradition of
justice antonin scalia campaigning in
wisconsin monday
former vice president joe biden appealed
to some of the same working-class voters
that elected mr trump in 2016.
the temple truth is that donald trump
ran for office
saying he would represent the forgotten
man and women in this country
and then once he got in office he forgot
us biden then tried to turn the focus
back to the president's handling of
coronavirus
he froze he failed to act he panicked
and america has paid the worst price of
any nation in the world
the u.s is now on the brink of 200 000
coronavirus deaths but the president
gives his response to the pandemic
an a plus he says any criticism is the
result of bad public relations
and fake news tony ben thank you very
much